sur chetcom on voit envoyer
le raid je vais tout mettre en place et
on va suivre le match
de Carlsen contre carwana faut que je
récupère les caméras mais ne vous
inquiétez pas tout ça va arriver très
vite
surtout que je réussisse à suivre les
joueurs déjà dans un premier temps
parce que comme j'étais dans le title
voilà hop le match qui est parti
alors pourquoi on voit pas les chic et
ça c'est une bonne question
ça c'est une excellente question et ben
voilà l'échiquier est déjà on le voit je
vais récupérer les câbles des joueurs
j'en ai pour une petite seconde
on va récupérer les cames et on va
suivre le match tranquillement ne vous
inquiétez pas on rate on rate en réalité
pas grand chose dans le sens où
tout simplement le match dure 4 heures
donc on a le temps
donc on a le temps attendez je vais
récupérer les caméras elles sont là
on voit du calfo ambulant
donc on va mettre sur la caméra du haut
on va bien le cadre
[Musique]
et après on va on va on va recadrer
Carlsen et on sera tranquille donc
erwana il a les noirs et je vais mettre
les bons noms et on sera tranquille
c'est pas car wanna c'est la caméra du
bas
car il est là plus qu'à mettre les deux
noms des deux joueurs
et espérer que les scores soient dans le
bon ordre
la cadence c'est le 5 plus simple
et le timer je sais pas pourquoi il se
il se déclenche pas
je vais essayer de déclencher le timer
mais depuis l'autre jour il se déclenche
pas il faut que je fasse manuellement
je sais pas pourquoi il déclenche pas
je le déclenchais je vais en faire un
manuellement bon du coup est-ce qu'on a
tout qui est bon
ça a l'air les amis
on va voir qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
de ce match du coup dans le chat
Magnus notre Valérian du tournoi ouais
je crois que
c'est un peu le cas
ouais sa chambre c'est le bordel ça a
pas l'air super bien rangé côté mcdoche
sa maman a pas dû assez l'engueuler
dis Magnus favori mais car on a beaucoup
amélioré en fait moi je savais pas le
dossier avec cette queue du 5 + 5
j'aurais dit que c'est pas si clair
coupé chambre d'ado ouais
il a il va il va sur ses 31 ans déjà
comme on est sûr que les gens ne
trichent pas derrière leur écran alors
on n'est pas sûr mais sur ce tournant là
il y aura pas de problème il y a
d'autres tournants il y a pu avoir des
problèmes mais sur celui-là il y en aura
pas il y a pas assez d'argent et du coup
et comme c'est du Blitz on va pas dire
que le risque est trop grand parce que
c'est pas un grand risque tricher mais
c'est
[Musique]
c'est pas un tournoi sur lequel on a
réellement vu d'irrégularités ou
quasiment pas bizarre riz
en tout cas pas entre ces deux joueurs
là
bon après on n'est jamais sûr à 100%
mais c'est pas le tournoi ce c'est un de
ceux dans lequel il y a le moins
d'argent en réalité
force à cafards
à [ __ ] du match ouais mais on a rien à
[ __ ] non plus donc à la rigueur ça
équilibre
ça fait pas énormément baisser de niveau
en blitz sur quelque chose de long comme
ça d'en avoir rien à [ __ ] c'est pas
une telle différence en quelque sorte
il a joué bécois trop Carlson
turbizarre c'est position de de type un
peu ragozy là avec ses poussées de pions
qu'on va souvent dans la Rago
et donc il fait fouger 6
le mec en haut ressemble un gars de la
commune
non
après c'est vrai que il est à la BAC up
car wanna certains ont pu le voir dans
le dans la rediff
je vois bien car on a gagné contre
Carlson ok moi je suis plutôt pour Fabi
on va se mettre du côté de Magnus pour
suivre le match mais moi je serai plus
plus pour famille
après je pense que pas l'algorithme de
98% et je vois pas dans quel monde il a
une chance mais
là ça se passe mal c'est bien joué qui
avait les H2 et F3 ce que dame prend ici
ça arrive sur échec et à te repenser si
ça la fin ouais bien joué de la part de
Minus il a spot le truc Obs regardez il
a fait B6 carwana et au moment où il a
joué B6
il a compris que toute cette variante
avec tout reprendre c'est 6 à la fin les
marchés parce que le pion c'est 6
n'était plus soutenu et ça c'est très
très bien joué de la part de magnouch
allez on a vu mcdouche Marshall ce
weekend mais là on voit Magnus Carlsen
c'est un peu en dessous mais ça joue
très bien
ouais et il prend et des cas
et des quatre c'est bien joué qui est G4
alors est-ce qu'il peut jouer peut-être
sur un truc comme pion prank cavalier
prend pour prendre est-ce que ça peut
marcher
je montre l'idée
en maths donc on va voir si c'est ce qui
fait
non il a fait tourcer 3 il a raté l'idée
peut-être ou alors il y avait un autre
problème que j'ai pas vu alors que
l'ordi donner des pros 3 comme main OK
mes tours C3 a l'air con
fait 4 tête tour C8 attention quand même
Magnus là il m'a pas l'air à ultra
précis
ah c'est marrant il joue pas du tout le
réseau de maths alors qu'il aurait pu
tenter tour C8 tours C1 j'ai
l'impression que ça lui a complètement
échappé que le roi était en réseau
j'ai l'impression que l'idée lui a
échappé où il y a un truc qui m'a
échappé aussi de plus complexe
F4 des 3 F5
des deux allez c'est quand même pas si
mal ce qui fait Fabien il y aura tour C1
ouais Magnus qui m'a pas l'air ultra
précis
après c'est intéressant ce que je vous
fais bien au
pourquoi pas mettre un punto déjà à côté
italien en ce début de match
ouais attention quand même Magnus de pas
trop jouer la main dans le slibard
ça pourrait coûter cher là il y a encore
du Tour des 7 ouais qui tombe et qui a
l'air fort ça va peut-être passer quand
même pour Magnus et oui
les cartes de niveau est tel quand même
allez Fabi il faut réussir à voler quand
même un demi point ici
malgré la difficulté
mais là il va pas réussir à l'arrêter ce
Punto eux tours des 8
et oui ça fait Punto pour mag Nouche il
est pas bien Fabi
ça fait un point on va voir si on a les
caméras et les scores du bon côté
ah ouais non ça l'envers donc il faut
qu'on remette tout à l'envers
terrible
donc c'est
ouais alors attendez ouais faut changer
les trucs de place c'est hyper chiant
mais je suis obligé de le faire donc on
a pas le choix
il faut que je change les scores de
place
au moins on a des trucs dans le bon
ordre avec les scores automatiques
ça fait déjà un
zéroanna peut répondre
à Magnus
car on a sa tête j'ai besoin d'un
conseil en rayon informatique de la Fnac
c'est censé finir à quelle heure alors
ça commence à 19h c'est censé finir à 23
heures
qu'il a joué des cinko ici
mais la pression sur 4 demain à 19h il y
aura mvl contre
contre Wesley Sow et surtout jeudi
magnifique journée avec deux matchs de
speech normalement qui seront coup sur
coup alors j'ai pas encore l'horaire
mais je soupçonne qu'ils vont tenter de
faire
17h 1h du mat donc ce sera le marathon
speechers extraordinaire et la finale
vendredi
là ça va jeudi vraiment vraiment belle
journée avec deux matchs ou sur coup
demain je regardais MV Alouette demain
il y aura il y aura Maxime donc sera 19h
à 23h aussi c'est le mail la même la
même heure qu'aujourd'hui et normalement
la finale si possible ils vont garder
cette horaire aussi
qui rouget ou pas non ça l'intérêt c'est
pas après par exemple nepo il jouait pas
non plus à 100 % voilà faut pas faut pas
penser que les joueurs jouent ça à 100%
ce serait vraiment une
une grossière erreur alors certains tu
vas même Magnus je joue pas à 100% après
le truc c'est qu'il y a tellement de
parties que si quelqu'un est plus fort
ça fait quand même l'écart il y a des
changements à part a priori ok robinside
bah c'est dommage là les deux demi ou
sur coup je sais pas pourquoi j'ai le
timer qui qui démarre pas en fait je
dois faire une connerie c'est pas
possible moi je vais je vais récupérer
un autre chronomètre
jeudi et vendredi et là il a finalement
mardi aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe robinside
après c'était
d'un côté c'est mieux et d'un autre côté
c'est moins bien
il y a un côté mieux un côté moins bien
je suis en train de récupérer un chrono
un autre chrono
qui marche
et qui est pas mal non plus en fait
et qui est pas mal non plus
c'est beaucoup trop simple c'est pas de
changement dernière minute ouais
bah complètement
Fabien Carlson rivalité sous côté pas
vraiment sous côté c'est juste qu'elle
est à sens unique
je pense que le match va être long pour
famille si il commence mal
si dans le 5 + 5 et sac à dos il arrive
déjà pas à se mobiliser le match va être
extrêmement long
il gagne quoi le vainqueur du speech je
crois 20000 dollars
et peut-être une prime peut-être ça fait
30 000 en tout
peut-être même 40 je sais pas
mais arrive à sûrement car podcast
ouais c'est vraiment peu ouais
par rapport à la longueur des matchs et
la difficulté du tournoi c'est c'est
assez peu
j'ai pris par match premier match j'ai
gagné 3200
dit Maxime
ça dépend aussi du score ouais c'est un
peu compliqué mais c'est pas énorme non
genre
championne chips ou un truc comme ça
mais oui et après ça tu gagnes des trucs
par match machin c'est peut-être 40000 à
la fin si tu gagnes vraiment le tournoi
le goba ils ont mis des prix dedans il
s'est pris sont quand même largement
corrects bah ici c'est les prix plutôt
normaux mais c'est il y a tellement une
envolée des prix dans les tournois que
ça paraît peu par rapport à ce qui a pu
avoir dans d'autres tournois
mais c'est aussi pour ça que c'est pas
le genre de tournoi sur lequel ça va
tricher il y a tellement de tournois à
côté
ou c'est plus intéressant de tricher et
en plus c'est des cadences plus enfin
c'est moins grillé c'est plus facile de
tricher et il y a plus de prix donc là
c'est vraiment pas le bon tournoi pour
pour tricher pour pour ceux qui le
veulent
c'est prendre des risques pour pour pas
grand chose au final
c'est aussi pour ça que le tournoi est
sympa
mais oui forcément la les quarts de
finale mercredi
demi finale jeudi et finale vendredi là
le triptyque ça devait pas plaire à tout
le monde c'est vrai que pour Maxime et
Wesley c'était un désavantage clair
c'est vrai que pour eux ce serait
nettement mieux si leur quart de finale
était mercredi et leur demi-finale
vendredi c'est quand même plus logique
faut être j'aime pour intégrer le SCC
non pas forcément moi j'ai tenté la
calife
je me suis pas qualifié
mais tu es pas obligé d'être grand
maître pour tenter de te qualifier c'est
juste que t'obliger d'être dans les
meilleurs mondiaux pour y arriver
tu sais ou non ok donc là on est dans
une finale avec un pion de moins pour
Fabiano qui subit déjà fortement alors
après je sais pas si Magnus va jouer à
100 % tout le match mais on sent que ça
peut être long pour pour Fabi
tension de pas faire fouger 6 là ça va
me prendre ici je peux faire mal
ça je vais contre qui au calife j'ai
joué j'ai joué la première qualif
première qualif et j'ai perdu la partie
importante j'ai battu un mec à 3000 j'ai
battu sévillian j'ai battu amer j'ai
battu quelques très forts et après j'ai
perdu contre dalle mais j'ai pas eu de
chance sur mon tournoi parce que c'était
j'aurais dû aussi faire la deuxième
calife parce que là la première qualif
ça a été le dernier grand coup d'éclat
d'énormément de joueurs qui étaient très
fort au title qui ont aussi été très
fort à ce s à cette première calife du
speechess et après cette première calife
du speechestre il y a énormément de
joueurs comme une épidémie qui ont qui
ont vu leur une baisse de niveau assez
conséquente
dans les dans les tournois suivantes et
c'est peut-être et c'est peut-être cette
épidémie qui m'a qui me touche aussi
ouais c'est joueur tu les voyais toutes
les semaines ils étaient
gagner les titles des machins et tout et
après et après ce tournoi ça a pris
toute leur énergie terrestre
il y a une il y a une difficulté pour
certains
c'est plus tout à fait les mêmes joueurs
que dans un moment
plus les mêmes top 3
donc cette finale elle est pas simple à
gagner parce que le pion c'est il est
très difficile à avancer pour pour
Fabiano la tour c'est on voit qu'elle
est bien placée en face du Punto pour
pour faire bien au moins pour Magne donc
[Musique]
après c'est forcément un avantage
puisque c'est un pion de plus et le jour
on réussit à ce groupe voilà j'avais
vous le dire avec un coup comme Dan D5
parce qu'il y a pas tout reprendre c'est
7 à cause de tourner un tour à chat là
on a toujours passé 5 à Tours français 5
dames prendre des trois mais si réussi à
avancer le pion il sera nettement mieux
donc qui dribble te reprend ses 7 je
sais pas si là pour des deux tours des
trois il essaye de récupérer un peu de
temps ces 6 tours pensaient si il veut
toujours tourner un et là maintenant il
a ses cinq qui avancent Fabiano qui
s'est décalé et maintenant c'est C4 et
oui c'est pour ça que l'avantage il
était clairement au noir
parce que le pion il avance
et il avance vite et fort
et ça va déjà faire de zéro pour le
Champion du monde en titre
encore pendant quelques mois
gros début de match de Magnus qui peut
déjà vraiment mettre la tête sous l'eau
là de Fabiano à 3-0 bon déjà que l'ordi
donner 98% c'est déjà quasi match plié
en réalité
après faudra qu'il mène son match
jusqu'à la fin mais il est en train de
l'exploser façon puzzle
Fabiano il aurait peut-être fallu
envoyer cales plutôt
c'était peut-être plus fort côté calife
seulement 98% de chance de gagner moi
j'ai annoncé 100%
la côte à 1,05 c'était pris ici
pour pour ma douche parce que je vois
pas trop dans quel monde il gagne pas
puis là après le 2-0
mais bon on s'est compris
tu as parié je vais pas parier mais
ça c'est une variante
je crois qu'il y avait été mis à la mode
par un certain ici piano
car on a envie de c'est pas incroyable
bah regarder la différence de Hello
Magnus Carlsen de 3285 élo Fabiano
caroanna 300019
c'est comme si jouait un match pendant 4
heures contre un mec qui est 26 20 ou 26
sur chescom on est Lomax je vais quand
même me sentir favori quoi
et là en plus Fabien Magnus
à ce niveau là l'écart est encore plus
important en réalité parce que plus on
monte dans la pyramide des lots plus
l'écart est important l'écart de niveau
il va pas
traversée alors après il est capable
de coup d'éclat Fabiano ça c'est vrai en
[ __ ] il y a des jours quand il en forme
il peut il peut vraiment avoir un
excellent niveau mais contre Magnus en
plus il y a un passif quand même entre
les deux hommes en rapide et en blitz et
en longue aussi qui fait que
a quand même un avantage psychologique
important alors sur deux quatre six
parties il peut se passer quelque chose
mais sur 4 heures c'est difficile
de dire 90% c'est chaud ouais mais bon
tu sais
on connaît bien ce format de speech il y
a très très peu de surprises
de grosses surprises
par exemple Maxime qui avait battu
Carlsen c’est dans le domaine du
possible et d'ailleurs Maxime avait
gagné
évidemment c'était une surprise Magnus
était favori mais surprise est possible
après quand l'écart de niveau est trop
important il y a je me rappelle pas de
il y avait eu une grosse surprise
c'était Douda contre je sais plus
c'était gris Tchouk ou caryakin qu'il
avait battu mais en fait Douda c'est
juste qu'on savait pas qu'il est aussi
fort qu'il l'était donc tu peux avoir
des surprises de joueurs moins connus
deux jeunes par exemple la Sarine Siba
et Carouge serait très surpris mais
c'est dans le domaine du possible
on sait moins jusqu'où ils peuvent
s'arrêter quoi
la carwana et Carlsen ça fait longtemps
qu'ils sont sur le circuits les deux
hommes ont beaucoup joué ensemble on
connaît bien les deux profils
c'est une surprise ou pas
petite mais c'est une petite surprise
c'est une surprise
de tous les formats ouais mais Magnus en
plus contre Maxime le match up est pas
super pour lui Maxime en blitz il a
quand même d'assez bons résultats contre
Magnus il le gène souvent et il le gène
en tactique et sur des matchs longs ça
peut enrayer la confiance
donc le match up faisait en plus que
surprise était
on va pas ouais on va dire vraiment
possible c'est un truc tu dis bon c'est
un peu un traquenard tu vois c'est un
peu ce qu'on appelle le matcha et ce
match c'est un traquenard pour pour
Magnus et il est plus fort mais bon
ça peut ça peut ressembler à traquenard
la caméra déjà sacrée champion du
speechestre ou pas non parce que si je
joue contre Magnus en finale Magnus sera
favori
ouais c'est un peu un France Maroc tu
sens un trackmar possible France Maroc
tu sais France favorite c'est un peu
c'est un peu ça ouais
mais si le Maroc bat la France tu seras
pas non plus choqué quoi
là ça ressemblerait plus à Argentine
Arabie Saoudite
bon ça peut arriver mais si la victoire
tu dis que c'est un des plus grosses de
l'histoire de la Coupe du monde
à quoi servait de jouer ce n'est pas de
surprise bah après le format est fait
pour qu'il y ait pas de surprise par
contre
format vraiment qui est qui est fait
pour limiter au maximum le possibilité
de surprise
pour vraiment être sûr que ce soit les
meilleurs qui gagnent à chaque fois
ça va vraiment comme si au foot on
jouait en 8 matchs
quand c'est des équipes de niveau
similaires ça peut gagner mais là tu
aurais plus de
on a quasiment plus après qui ouais bon
là la partie a été bien joué de part et
d'autre dans cette catalane
et amulette car on a un bon niveau là
Magnus c'est très largement gagnant de
la
le 5 puissance c'est la meilleure
cadence de Fabian au probablement contre
Magnus
seule chose qui peut arriver à Magnus
c'est un relâchement là on sent qu'il
est pas super concerné par le match il
est il joue très tranquille alors ça
suffit parce que son niveau
estratosphérique le match commence très
bien donc faut pas qu'ils se repose trop
sur ces lauriers
ma position
elle doit se tenir pour les Noirs mais
c'est un peu comme la partie précédente
c'est quand même un pion de moins
encore que là les Noirs ont quand même
de l'activité
ce que c'est la preuve classique ouais
j'ai quelques news mais c'est pas c'est
pas giga bien organisé honnêtement
donc j'ai du mal à donner des news
exactes il y a quelques trucs très
bizarre
en fait il y a un truc bizarre là dans
la prochaine League je sais pas comment
ça va se passer encore mais
[Musique]
mais en fait on est obligé d'aligner des
joueurs attends je sais pas si encore
Maxime dans le chat mais ça c'est un
truc qui mal Lucine alors évidemment on
n'en aura pas Maxime de le faire mais il
y a un truc j'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'on oblige les équipes à jouer
des des joueurs qui jouent dans les
équipes à jouer des tournois individuels
qui ont aucun rapport pour le classement
des genres de journées me VIP
je peux pas comprendre ça en fait c'est
déjà manager l'équipe c'est un enfer
c'est vraiment compliqué ça prend
beaucoup de temps etc et
je sais pas pourquoi on rajoute aux gens
tu as déjà les joueurs qui jouent pour
la grande majorité gratuitement enfin
pas complètement gratuitement parce que
il y aura il y a quand même un price
pour intéressant plus intéressant que
les années précédentes
mais
force la nul il y a pas tout reprendre
un truc
je sais pas mais donc du coup ouais je
sais pas j'ai pas
j'ai pas la rêve de
pourquoi ils font ça donc je sais pas
encore et puis il y a des choses qui
vont être modifiées parce que ça c'est
par exemple quelque chose que je pense
les joueurs vont pas vont pas trop aimer
en fait ça fait chier tout le monde en
vrai
genre d'Arena spécial pro Chelsea League
enfin qui a envie de se faire chier en
fait
personne
mais après ça dépend combien ils mettent
de prix exactement pour pour ce truc
spécifiquement mais il y a il y a des
bizarres comme ça après la compétition
sera sympa à jouer
c'est encore un avantage pour les blancs
il y a toujours ce pion de plus et puis
au moment où ils veulent ils font de la
même 5 échec de toute façon
pourquoi est-ce qu'on concerne pas avec
les participants pour réfléchir au
format bah en réalité il se concerte
avec les participants merle 83b mais
comme souvent on a des intérêts assez
contraires avec les autres participants
parce qu'on est la seule équipe
ou une des deux seules équipes peut-être
mais avec les chats bras mais les chats
bras c'est vraiment minime par rapport à
nous quand même qui allons vraiment
faire ça pour faire de l'audience et
pour faire un truc un peu en mode sport
et du coup pour vraiment avoir des
supporters faire des soirées etc et qui
fait vraiment en mode en mode équipe et
toutes les autres équipes en fait tous
les autres joueurs ils se mettent entre
eux pour pour se faire du fric sur la
compétition donc on est les seuls qui
ont un intérêt on va dire marketing dans
l'événement et donc on a des intérêts
qui sont pas du tout les mêmes que ceux
des autres équipes en fait
ouais
donc c'est un peu notre difficulté
c'est un peu notre difficulté comme on
est les seuls à penser au développement
des échecs et aux côtés
marketing et
streamable entre guillemets ou
retransmissible de la compétition c'est
c'est ça crée un peu ce
porte-à-faux
bon ça fait un Nimzo
cette fois ci avec le pion C4 qui va
pouvoir être mis sous pression
donc normalement un des plans ce serait
de jouer avec C5 B6 x 6 cavalier C6
cavaliers à 5 mettre une tour en C8 et
gagner le pion à C4 ici commence par
cavalier A5 H5 pour damage 4
qui vont faire il va faire ça
c'est bien qu'ils organisent la
prochesse League etc mais après ils
peuvent rien y faire eux non plus si les
autres équipes s'organisent pas comme
nous
après eux ils ont voulu faire un truc un
peu plus eSport juste ils ont pas réussi
parce que
ils ont vraiment eu le projet de faire
des échecs une grosse compétition eSport
avec avec des équipes connues etc mais
simplement
le coût de la participation à la Ligue
pour pour les structures étaient
tellement élevées par rapport au
retombées économiques que c'était pas
possible
du coup dans un deuxième temps ils ont
décidé de se
réappuyer sur les acteurs historiques
des échecs
sauf que à part nous et peut-être
Yarou mais je pense même pas qu'il le
fasse pour cet événement précis mais à
part nous et Kiko il y a personne qui
va même essayer de faire IP ce genre
d'événement en fait
d'une manière on va dire compétition et
sportive
bon peu importe c'est pour la petite
explication pour ceux que ça intéressait
noir
c'est des deux meilleures formant
internet c'est grâce à moi c'est vrai
après les deux formations extrêmement
améliorables mais de manière
assez incroyable et étonnante personne
c'est même m'approcher de faire mieux ce
qui a ça lui sinon
donc 5 c'est bien joué c'était pour
éviter de se faire fixer
les autres participent juste pour
gratter est une facile ouais et les
autres équipes ouais globalement
mais après ça dérange pas ni
ou alors il y a aussi des messages qui
font des équipes
il y a ça il y a des mécènes qui font
des équipes mais en vrai ça dérange pas
trop parce que tu as besoin de de
ce genre d'équipe aussi pour lancer un
truc seulement la prochaine League ils
ont peut-être eu les yeux un peu trop
trop gros avec Winx Gambit ils ont voulu
changer le format et il y a aussi
beaucoup de problèmes de triche en
réalité c'était vraiment un ni à triche
de A à Z aussi donc c'est une
compétition qui a dure du mal à prendre
sa place mais
c'est quoi le dernier message qui font
des équipes comme ça
on sait pas trop pourquoi mais
mais oui
trop d'argent ouais
la position elle a l'air vraiment cool
pour Magnus
ces pions triplés là ils sont quand même
bizarres
il est peut-être pas mieux peut-être en
effet d'optique parce qu'il a les Noirs
mais il y a des pions bizarres quand
même ici
d'être amené le cavalier F6 je me
demandais s'il y a pas un plan comme H6
G5 quand même x 8 où j'ai 6 ouais il
part peut-être pour ça
j'imagine que le cavalier va repartir en
4 ouais
on n'est pas forcément obligé de le
prendre parce que si il prend peut
reprendre de G avec les noirs et
peut-être du coup avoir le pion F5 pour
un peu fermer les diagonales
après le cavalier peut refilant des 6 ça
va peut-être quand même pour les blancs
bien joué le cavalier 5 qui gagne un
tempo sur H7
et on bloque bien le pion de 5 mois ça
doit être sensiblement égal les deux
joueurs ont leurs atouts
H5
mais oui on n'arrive pas trop à attaquer
la loi c'est bien joué
intéressant
il va prendre de quoi est-ce qu'il
réussisse est-ce qu'il va pas se faire
choper une tour en fait
ce qui a pas un truc avec X3 fougères 6
c'est la et la tour se retrouve sans
case
peut-être
ça peut
ouais c'est exactement ce qui se passe
du coup il fait 4 intermédiaires pour
pour se libérer mais c'est un peu comme
le match
du carou hier
début de match très difficile pour les
vans mais après les vannes est un peu
revenu alors
ikaro à contrôler tout le match mais ça
c'est pas complètement envolé
mais on voit Magnus sur la CAM qui est
un peu un peu désespéré
je vous annonce qu'après cette partie il
y aura une pause
la première
sans Fabiano confiance mesdames.fr
important les pauses ah bah oui Maxime
ça va te permettre de regarder le score
du match demain
entre
OK
il peut menacer à tout moment du
cavalier prime 3 attention
elle est peut-être pas ça oh il y a qu'à
aider trois cavaliers de maths aussi qui
peut partir
ok donc il fait pousser 5
ce qui va jouer un coup droit H7 pour
anticiper les échecs
et voir comment les Blancs jouent
il fait cavalier des trois
sur tour B8 il veut quoi
il veut juste qu'il prend F4 pour
prendre 8
et roi bouge d'accord et le pioneait
et sur un coup de dames comme dame il
n'y a pas des milliers de cases c'est 7
il va jouer un cool lambda mais
peut-être dame G6 ok donc il fait tomber
8 quand même il est change
et fout des quatre
sera cloué
à cause de ton projet 7 c'est malin mais
là l'ordinateur donne égal à prix
cavalier H3
qui est dur à trouver il a fait cavaler
des trois pour jouer pour E5 et fermer
le fou
donc il l'empêche
la finale paraît un poil juste après
cavalier F2 qui fait tour à deux il doit
vouloir tout à quatre tours C4
maintenant il fait cavalier F2 ouais il
a gagné un tempo c'est bien joué
ce qui va avoir il a la même position
avec la tour en a deux
donc il attaque le pion à 4
qui va pouvoir récupérer
il remet la tour en C2 c'est bien joué
aussi maintenant il va mettre la tour en
deux en C2 il va en récupérer un de
Punto
il en récupère pas 2 pour le moment il
le prend maintenant il va y avoir
d'accord et là tu auras C4 et il
récupère encore un punto il va réussir à
faire nul
ça fait mal pour pour Faby
attention quand même les finales de
pions
ça allait pas vraiment dangereuse ça
fait match nul et ça file en pause non
là la partie elle va être arrêtée
et sa fille en pause
ça fait ça fait trois ans pour pour
Magnus dans un match qui domine pour le
moment
assez facilement je dirais
parce qu'on le sent
j'ai pas envie de dire en retenue parce
que c'est pas c'est pas le terme mais on
le sent pas on le sent pas se donner à
10000 à 10000% et pourtant
sans grande difficulté il réussit à
garder à garder la tête
et les épaules
ça va être long bah ça dépend tant que
tant qu'il y a pas un écart
qui est creusé
j'ai envie de te dire écoute ça joue
mais dès qu'il va y avoir une différence
qui va qui va être faite parce que là
deux points bon c'est un mini break mais
ça peut toujours revenir dès que ce sera
plus 4 + 5 ce sera ce sera terminé après
c'est vrai que cette section de 5 + 1
elle est tellement longue
c'est c'est hyper long parce que tu sens
que le match tu as envie qu'il se
décante et tu sens que de toute façon
c'est Carl scène qui va prendre le
dessus à la fin mais bon voilà c'est
comme ça
car pour le moment trois points pour
Griffon d'Or
là c'est la petite pause les joueurs qui
vont revenir normalement c'est 5 minutes
je crois
je viens avec quatre pions de moi ouais
mais après je pense qu'elle était
vraiment nulle la finale parce que c'est
tout était trop active et les pions
étaient trop trop simple
vous pensez que les matchs joueurs se
préparent avant le match pour le Bullet
il joue un petit peu ouais mais bon
c'est pas non plus ils font pas une
semaine de
une semaine de belette
avec
il est pas bien
en anglais on dit belette plutôt que
boulette
belette
et donc ce soir le match c'est quoi
c'est Argentine Croatie
vous avez un favori
prolongation
ça va être un match serré non
mais la Croatie ils ont bien joué depuis
le début de la compète
un sacré mental OK
et vous la sentez la défaite de la
France demain ou pas du tout
avec les joueurs qui commencent à être
malade peut-être une épidémie de covid
ou je sais pas quoi
non pas du tout
ah ça peut
ça peut demain des fêtes de la France
après c'est pas sûr évidemment
premier pas là Carlsen ce qu'ils font la
pause
pause jusqu'à combien je pense ça
devrait reprendre la d'ici une minute
maximum en réalité
je pense que ça devrait commencer d'ici
très peu de temps
que ça reprenne je sais pas normalement
c'était 5 minutes de pause
là je crois que c'est ça fait plus que 5
minutes là déjà ça fait 6 ou 7
Fabien en full détente
allez ça repart
Manu ça les blancs
mais ça part sur une pétrole
peut pas avoir le match il est pas bien
ouais c'est sûr que ça le fait suer non
Maxime là pour le coup
je me rappelle qu'il y avait un match de
speechers où il s'est allumé une télé et
regarder le match en même temps je sais
plus contre qui par contre
mais c'était une télé regarder le match
mais là je sais pas s'il peut le faire
mais oui il doit avoir le SAM de rater
le match là c'est sûr c'est évident
ça c'est sûr que ça va le mettre mal
toi tu as pas de bol de jouer Wesley
demain parce que ouais c'est j'imagine
qu'il en a absolument rien à [ __ ]
fabiche c'est pas d'origine italienne
normalement ça doit quand même un peu
regarder
ça doit suer quand même un peu
je préfère voir un Veil que le foot
terrible quand même préfère voir le foot
est-ce que tu préfères te regarder dans
la glace ou est-ce que tu préfères voir
la demi-finale de Coupe du monde
portant quand même
ne m'en parle pas
à la demi-finale
déjà quand on a raté le car on était pas
trop on n'était pas tout à fait bien en
plus France Maroc en 2000 c'est quand
même
gros match
quoi
je pense pas non je pense pas qu'il ait
le droit maximum d'avoir
l'écran en même temps
sinon ça va mettre du pH aussi ça va
mettre un peu trop de choses
non mais Magnus il aurait l'écran s'il
avait le droit Magnus il aurait l'écran
c'est sûr il l'a déjà fait de regarder
le foot pendant
il a déjà fait le multiplex
en tout cas c'est encore une position
intéressante pour Magnus il avait le
foot casse blanche encore il serait bien
en C4
jamais facile à évaluer c'est pion isole
c'est pion isolé avec le pion en C6 et
Vlad n'a pas du tout expliqué cette
structure s'il y avait plus de foodcasse
blanche
parce que normalement avec le fond en C4
on veut plutôt ça avec h3g4 et
éventuellement après même du fktro
donc dur à dire mais ce que je sais
c'est que avec le pion en C6 le pion
isolé moins grave qu'avec le pion aussi
pour une raison assez simple à
comprendre c'est que normalement quand
tu as le pion isolé tu vas avoir un peu
plus d'attaque sur le roi adverse et que
lorsque le pion est en C6 bah du coup il
est pas allé le roi et c'est plus facile
d'attaquer
de la merde
c'est un peu moins
normalement tu es content quand même
d'avoir le fou qui tape là sur cette
diagonale et là tu l'as pas
donc c'est un peu moins intéressant pour
les blancs
même si dans tous les cas il y a un
avantage de développement on va quand
même réussir à toucher la case 5 je
pense pas que les Blancs puissent être
moins bien je vois pas pourquoi il
serait vraiment mieux non plus
[Musique]
OK
5 ça peut être comme intéressant ça
menace dame pro F7
c'est pas du tout proposé par l'ordi
je peux pas dire comme ça intuitivement
pourquoi de manière directe
il fait ah j'ai trois j'aime beaucoup
ouais ça c'est un très joli coup ouais
c'est tellement bien joué
ouais j'ai trois c'est très très fort
parce que ça enlève tous les mats du
couloir ça fait bille des cases blanches
mais qui peuvent pas être attaqués et ça
permet foue 4 ok c'est vraiment fort
j'ai trois je quand je réfléchissais je
pense à fois 4 mais j'ai trois ça fait
juste la même chose en mieux
bien joué et cavaliers à 5 qui avait pas
cavalier prend B7 à cause de tour B8
mais là encore c'est plutôt Fabiano qui
joue les bons coups ici
on peut même prendre de G et après je
vais pour F5 fougères 5
un Magnus là qui a du mal sur les
dernières parties
dommage du début de match un peu en
dedans de Fabi qui a eu du mal à rentrer
et maintenant Magnus n'est plus du tout
dominant
il joue quand même Sega il m'arrive il
est pas en train d'être
mis au supplice par Fabiano non plus
mais
plus forcément des cars de niveau sur
ces parties là
je trouve que c'est même Fabiano qui est
en train de donner une petite leçon de
pion isolé à son homologue norvégien
une position meilleure regarder ce roi
en plus un bien protégé et là maintenant
il échange l'option isolé mais dans de
bonnes conditions pour taper sur les
diagonales il fait vraiment une
excellente partie Fabiano et regardez ce
pion c'est comme si le pion H2 était en
F3 il serait nettement mieux en
F3 quand H2 et regarder quelque part
cette structure là avec ce pion H7 qui
servira à rien et qui est sur la bonne
case pour contrôler la diagonale et les
cases du cavalier
c'est vraiment une superbe géométrie là
pour le joueur américain
on va voir il faut qu'il décale sa tour
ouais donc tour C3
la comment est-ce qu'il va s'organiser
la dame doit passer probablement sur la
case C6 ou B7 peut-être tu vas faire B6
dame B7 il a joué dame du tourage 5
c'est bien joué encore une fois il y a
peut-être H4 quand même surtout rage 5
il fait B6 maintenant
ça menace BK tu vas sûrement jouer à 5
des 4 à 3 c'est plutôt intéressant pour
les blancs ça chasse quand même le fou
il aurait peut-être dû quand même jouer
à 5 passe le chasser le foot cette belle
case
non Magnus qui réfléchit Magnus qui est
pas bien il peut pas vraiment toucher le
roi d'un mec 4 bonne idée d'échanger les
dames ici c'est plus lui qui peut se
faire toucher
ça va peut-être pas suffire une nouvelle
fois pour
pour Fabi
c'est peut-être assez solide côté côté
Magnus la position
mais il a réussi à mettre le set up mais
les pions sur blanc là encore c'est bien
joué son adversaire un fou de casse noir
il met le pion sur la sur la couleur
inverse
et là maintenant il doit réfléchir
est-ce qu'il échange des tours et ce qui
décale la tour
il décale en C de il veut bien échanger
en ayant la tour sur la troisième parce
qu'il y a pas d'entrée en D2 attention
quand même
parce que si la tour arrive sur la
seconde rangée pour les Noirs ça tapera
le pion F2 qui sera pas simple à
défendre il faut donc trouver les
couilles ici
des trois et pas mal joué
donc
mon H3 est ce qui serait bien placé pour
repartir vers F4 peut-être mais que au
cas d'un F6
après il peut peut-être mettre la tour
en F3 je pensais qu'il temporiserait sur
la case G5 en espérant F6 pour cavaler
H3 cavalier F4
mais bon il attend comme ça il doit
vouloir mettre un setup juste
et voir si les Noirs progressent
maintenant il va vouloir faire tout F3
cavaliers F4 et cavaliers D3 peut-être
pour réussir à naviguer le cavalier de
l'autre côté j'ai cinq et bien joué
c'est interdit tout F3
on échange un punto côté noir
c'est relativement bien joué
ah ça joue relativement bien un côté
Kawana
il met une réelle pression dans cette
partie
mais Magnus défend bien regarder une
nouvelle fois genre de forteresse
il contrôle les cases
il contrôle toutes les cases
pas sûr que ça fasse nul tension là de
pas se prendre un tour trois au mauvais
moment
avec le roi qui déboulerait rapidement
ça semble pas être le cas
la grosse question c'est tourgé trois
tout trois pour moi
il fait tourbé 4 ça marchait
probablement pas hein peut-être qu'il y
avait un cavalier un cavalier C2 qui
venaient couvrir les cases et qui
défendaient tout ces joueurs calculent
très vite évidemment et maintenant le
roi qui va arriver vers la case C2 ça ça
va être nul et c'est d'ailleurs même si
un joueur qui symboliquement pourrait
tenter c'est plus les blancs même si là
c'est vraiment trop nul
et que personne ne va rien tenter du
tout
c'est vraiment complètement égal
ça va échanger et sinco une nouvelle
fois et à 4 un petit peu comme dans une
partie
vu plutôt
ça refait nul
Fabiano qui réussit à
contenir maintenant les assauts de son
adversaire c'est même plutôt lui qui
attaque
mais sur ce temps fort il met pas de
points ce qui peut faire mal à la tête
c'est que la tête la moindre demi
occasion de Carlsen va se transformer en
point
Fabiano qui a les positions qui fait des
bonnes parties mais qui a réussi à
gagner
il a bien défendu jusqu'à maintenant
il défend il défend très bien
pardon
alors est-ce qu'il va envoyer du C4 du
B5
du C4 B5 aussi possible
famille qui a la position de balle mais
qui est menée au score ouais c'est un
peu ça enfin sur les dernières parties
parce que les deux victoires de Magnus
elles étaient
totalement mérité
puis on prend fou prend il va faire B3
ok ça va probablement rock puis Dame des
sisters C8 or B8 fois 7 fugue ça c'est
les plans classiques de pions isolés là
c'est une structure pion isolée un peu
plus classique que d'habitude avec la
structure comme je vous le disais avec 4
pions sur la loi
là normalement c'est fou j'ai 4 x 3
bizarres
il veut pas laisser le fou du fiancé
normalement c'était plutôt fougère
permettait de regagner un contrôle de la
case D4 le fouet 6 qui est mal placé
et là la position va être dure après
peut-être que fougères était mauvais
dans cette position
mais changer le foot case noir même si
je le comprends quand il est tôt il est
il est pénible
mais là c'est pas le bon c'est pas le
bon tempo
donc ça fait Tam prend c'est un prise
fougé quoi trop
cavalier eD4
vient taper cavalier prank cavalier
prendre peut-être tour FC 8 d'accord
et ça normalement c'est nul quand il y a
plus de tour
normalement ça gagne plus
c'est encore un avantage blanc mais
normalement ça tient après on Blitz
c'est pas une mauvaise chose de rentrer
là-dedans c'est zéro risque pour les
blancs et c'est chiant à jouer
mais sans plus
sans plus sans plus
l'avantagement à cause du pion isolé et
du fait que les noirs et le mauvais four
attention aussi
quand même on aurait le foot case noir
pour les Noirs ce serait quand même
plus intéressant
ça normalement Vlad m'avait dit que
c'était nul même s'il m'avait pas montré
en détail comment faire avait dit
normalement ça tient mais c'est vrai
c'est un peu chiant
après le fait qu'il soit rentré de
manière aussi
direct dedans
il connaît forcément mieux ce truc là
que moi
il se fait fixer un peu partout mais
ça peut passer
il a fait 4 c'est ouais d'accord il veut
transformer l'avantage mais
attention quand même parce que si on
prend fou prend
roi E5 roi E3 et qui a validé 5 déjà il
y a peut-être plus d'avantages après il
y a pas les pions sur la bonne couleur
c'est bon pour le défendre non pas
vraiment tu vas voir les tu veux qu'il
te reste les autres fous
il veut rentrer dans cette finale mais
normalement elle va être elle va être
nulle
[Musique]
complexe
OK
et ça permet aux cavaliers d'intervenir
en dessin
ça va sûrement être roi des trois qui
est des 5 la partie
et sur un truc comme cavalier B3 qui a
validé 5 cavaliers C5 il y a poussé 6
et le four en C6 il est pas aussi passif
quand c'est 8 et ça change tout
une nouvelle fois
ça c'est peut-être gaffe c'était juste
fouger 4 ça ça s'appelle peut-être Punto
hein
vous prend H5
B5 puis on prend B5 à 6 et au pire qui
est prend à 6 prises à 6 ça doit aller
pour G5 G4 pour draw
après
ce que ça maintient pas forcément la
menace mais bon il y a du cahier prend
B4 maintenant
franchement je sais pas un Dory moi
j'avais l'impression aussi mais après
pas sûr
c'était pas si simple quoi
donc 7
ok en fait j'ai l'impression que les
Noirs vont commencer à être mieux parce
que leur roi est tellement plus actif là
je pense à roi des quatre comme coup
après ça peut être dangereux roi des
quatre ça s'éloigne un peu des pions ici
mais bon
pour cavalier 6 qui apprend à 5
j'ai pas compris le coup cavalier 3 ici
j'ai pas compris la pub ah il veut aller
vers non j'ai pas compris la plus-value
en fait
peut-être qu'il veut foutais
je sais pas
ok roi des quatre et kf5 donc ça il veut
G5 HG cavaliers G4 ah c'est bien joué ça
de la part de Fabi
ouais mal jouer là de la Carlson qui a
fait quelques coups un peu en dessous à
mon avis
en fait c'était peut-être une connerie
parce que là c'est Fabi qui reprend le
qui reprend l'avantage
sur GH cavalier F5 qui veut roi D8
enfermer le fou
et cavalier G4 alors
vous B7
c'est sûr que c'est ce qui va jouer Faby
qui est pas giga facile ce soir
même quand il retourne un peu les
parties à Fabiano réussit à rester
dedans
après va réussir à jouer Roy fi3 G7 et
colmatais mais
Carlson qui doit s'employer
cavalier D7 il a 8
là je pense qu'il va faire un fou c'est
6 je pensais qu'il commencerait parfois
pousser 6
pour bloquer le cavalier le focaliser
c'est jouer maintenant
l'option à qui file tension sur les
capacités bulles et test et ouais ça va
peut-être faire la diff maintenant il va
y avoir du faux 4
déjà il y a H7 qui va dégager
il fait pousser deux d'abord il va
mettre le fond en B3 à 3 à 2 ça va jouer
à la pendule au cavalier 4 qu'est-ce que
c'est bien joué cavalier C3 chasses le
fou et à trois dames et oui sur les
capacités bel étés ça fait la DIV pour
Carlson et ça fait 4 ans et on a un
semblant de ce qu'on suivra en belette
et ouais toute la phase technique a été
super bien joué par karwana et en gros
manque de temps en qualité bel et test
il est en dessous
et c'est ça qui va qui va faire la
différence dans ce match
dans cette première heure et demie c'est
pas là que fait le score parce qu'il y a
peu de parties finalement 5 + 5 c'est
extrêmement long voilà plus 3 c'est
quand même déjà un énorme écart si
Magnus fait en fait ça plus 4
mais le choix de rentrer dans la finale
était pas forcément
le plus logique d'après moi et
l'exception isolée
après c'était une vraie pression on peut
pas lui reprocher ça mais il a pas
réussi à
bien
ouais
étonnant
étonnant en tout cas Magnus qui a pris
les les devants et qui commence à faire
enfler déjà cet écart
je pense que l'algorithme donne déjà
100% de chance de victoire à Magnus
j'imagine
ce qui est beau
manuscrit on rigole ou alors peut-être
qu'il y a eu un but bon je vais aller
check il y a peut-être eu un but là ça
rigolait de manière un petit peu étrange
là il y a des choses qui se passent
non pas de but mais bon ça aurait pu
être
00 pour le moment
après je pense que je vais plutôt être
pour la Croatie parce qu'un joueur qui
s'appelle Sosa je crois dans l'équipe de
Croatie
ce qui fait quand même plaisir comme nom
Scarface
pourtant ce Scarface
tout est dans le cas de Scarface de
toute façon
c'est plus beau film de l'histoire du
cinéma
à voir et à revoir
h400
H4 ouais complètement
cavalier prend F3 c'était dommage de se
faire attirer le rang F3 donc c'est
mieux de le faire dans ce sens là ouais
ça papa
ça vous dirait un ice cream avec mon ami
et moi
il va pouvoir aimer le cavalier en F5
il va pouvoir petit à petit prendre de
l'espace avec les Blancs
difficile pour les amateurs qui arrivent
toujours bien placé
je sais pas si il va essayer de monter
la position des pions ou pas aussi va
jouer essayer de jouer pour cavaler 3 kg
4 qui a lieu 5 c'est un peu mieux pour
les blancs ça va pas non plus être
gravissime c'est chiant avec les noirs
dire ça Tony Montana qui avait été pensé
pour être un anti héros
après ouais c'est trop
charismale patch c'est trop
j'ai cinq élèves3 H6 oh t'as jamais
envie tu foutrais tous tes pions sur
noir avec un fou de casse noir oh c'est
moche qu'est-ce que c'est moche ça c'est
ouais
c'est même pas à considérer ça
va être
dame 3 OK
toujours chiant parce qu'il y a cette
colonneuse si les noirs sont un peu
moins bien je pense c'est pour moi c'est
visuel mais c'est surtout cette
colonneur qui pose problème
cette case F5 maintenant pour le
cavalier
ça me Détroit il va revenir en F5 il va
faire dam F3 après pour essayer de
gagner le pion mauvaise structure pardon
ça c'est moi qui ai mal clic ouais
[Musique]
ça va commencer à être vraiment beaucoup
déjà trois aussi vite entre guillemets
dans le match c'est beaucoup
mais la 4 ça va commencer à être
prof ça l'est déjà mais c'est juste que
plus chaque point qui monte tu dis c'est
de plus en plus impossible à remonter
faites 4 même si tu en gagnes 2 à un
moment donné ce qui est déjà très dur tu
fais PAM bam tu gagnes 2 game en fait tu
as encore
deux points à remonter quoi
un Magnus il est beaucoup trop fort
il est train sa proie
elle a regardé ce cavalier en F5 il
contrôle toutes les cases le roi qui est
complètement bloqué c'est le roi blanc
qui va aller monter à la volée chercher
à H5 de 50 contre 36 secondes
c'est pas c'est pas un style magnifique
à voir mais c'est du efficacité
incroyable
c'est beaucoup trop
G5 ça va être 6
ça va monter monter mettre la pression
partout
il va faire DC full prend il va essayer
de caler peut-être une tour en E5 ou en
D2 je sais pas ça après c'est de la
précision c'est du calcul
le roi peut-être en F6 pour aller
réseauter le roi adverse il y a pas
d'échec un cavalier qui couvre c'est
trop
c'est trop dur pour Fabi
attention en ce match qui pourrait être
refusé sur sur les plateformes de
streaming habituel
ouais ça peut ouais il faut quand même
faire attention ici un pan et si vite
parti
avec un match pareil
ça peut déraper
ça peut vite déraper
et oui et oui
parce que là le score est en train de
d'augmenter dangereusement
encore
que je jouerais quand même F4 c'était
aussi dans mes dans mes mails parce
qu'il y a du tourage de
OK
ça tape le pion et sur des 4 il y a
assez 5 et tu reprends des 4 et ça c'est
Ciao
merci au revoir Fabiano
ce match va être long pour tout le monde
et surtout pour Magnus qui se dit je
dois rater
une demi-finale pour un tel match il
doit pas être bien my Nouche parce que
là le match
il était déjà quasi plié d'avance mais
là il est plié à d'autres chez pli ado
et oui ça doit être très très long pour
magnouche il doit être deg quand même
que ça tombe
Magnus encore plus sous les carwana
ouais c'est trop facile
c'est beaucoup trop facile
et heureusement la demi est claquée pour
l'instant il faut le dire à Magne mais
parce que ça doit pas être bien
après il est professionnel il faut aller
chercher le match il faut faire rentrer
l'argent
ah mais c'était sur ce face à face est
tellement en défaveur de
de Fabiano il est il est horrible pour
Fabiano face à face
c'est
les dures pour Fabiano de devoir jouer
encore lui pour lui aussi pour d'autres
raisons mais il a il a encore un
long match devant lui beaucoup de
parties enchaînés
ouais c'est chiant c'est chiant parce
que en plus comme c'est pas un format 7
et que les points s'additionnent
tu es quasiment fermé et juste tu
cliques pour cliquer quoi
quand il y a des grosses différences de
niveau c'est c'est long
terrible
il a le distribut il a le Woody bottes
Ed
important pour Fabi c'est call Flo qui a
le Woody le Woody Blitz stream
il peut abandonner après alors il a pas
le droit non il est obligé de jouer
jusqu'au bout
je pense que s'il avait le droit
le ferait peut-être
ça fait c'est fait la coupe de hand
c'est vrai d'ailleurs
en ce qui pourrait retrouver au
championnat du monde de [ __ ] c'est
rapide à la fin du mois
vous avez le droit mais Magnus
hésiterait pour aller voir le match et
ce qui donnerait deux points ou trois
points
pour se barrer une demi-heure et revenir
peut-être
il a donné un pion comme dit
précédemment au préalable et
mais il a de l'activité ça se voit il va
pouvoir peut-être envoyer du fourgon G4
ça se voit pas forcément net net mais on
voit le fousser hein on voit le cavalier
des quatre sous pression
donc
donc il évite les fougères pour échanger
après il peut prendre prendre et fousser
6 et après taper sur des 4
je me demandais si il y avait un dame B4
ici qui est quand même ça ça va
si on échange il y a un pion de moins
mais en fait le pion il surcasse noir il
pourra jamais avancer
c'est un truc à savoir c'est pas un
problème
[Musique]
mais combien de penalty dans cette Coupe
du Monde
l'Argentine j'ai l'impression que c'est
minimum leur cinquième pédo
ils en ont combien en fait j'ai un son
qu'à chaque fois ils ont des peaux
ah c'est Magnus qui a le penalty ce soir
bon ça ça va être tenu par Magnus
cavalier 6
ça va récupérer le pion et c'est égal
tu as pas G6
c'est qu'elle prend des quatre
attaque la tour tour des deux j'ai ici
c'est qu'elle prend des cartes
ouais
je suis arrivé en finale non mais là
c'est pas vraiment final c'est juste que
la position est bonne pour les noirs
je sais pas si on va commencer par F5
ouais sur cavalue 2 de toute façon il a
poussé 4
ouais bien dominer celle-là bien bien
belle ouverture en fait de Magnus
le gap est terrible entre les deux
trop de différence
il a jamais repris le pion des quatre en
fait qui bloque le fou attention de ne
pas le regretter un jour quand même
j'ai l'impression qu'il veut le mettre
sous pression
pour
pour se libérer
la pièce et peut-être aller chercher de
l'eau
ça y est c'est le chrono
qui nous lâche
c'était une heure trente de 5 + 5
voilà ça devrait il devrait réussir à
faire nul quand même dans cette finale
Faby
je n'ai pas l'impression
il y a pas de tour à chut contrôle
heureusement
il se formait super long quand les
matchs sont esquiver c'est la sixième
saison la septième sixième
donc il fait tour des 8
attention quand même pour Fabi la finale
peut être un peu bizarre
bon ça a l'air d'aller
ça va faire nul
il va quand même peut-être tenté une ou
deux arnaques mais bon le score est déjà
tellement fait
pas l'impression qu'il puisse vraiment
créer de menace
parce que son son peut pas détacher son
roi de la protection du pion
il aura bien défendu Fabi
ça fait nul et ça doit être la dernière
avant le 3 + 1 ça fait 6 degrés bon les
gars
et déjà net
9 minutes de pause maintenant
dans un match pas enfin propre
techniquement mais pas pas passionnant
de par
de par son scénario
complexe
c'était protégé par le fou
finir par un 23,5 non ça va finir à plus
8 + 9
il va pas prendre complètement l'eau
il va pas complètement prendre l'eau
mais
mais il est pas bien quoi
ouais c'est compliqué
c'est moins fini le foot que ça mais
pas bien engagé ouais
les échecs en tout cas c'est vraiment
plié
le foot de 0 il y a encore un petit
monde mais bon ça fait quand même mal de
zéro un
genre de fauteuil non sur son
canapé c'est quoi ce truc un peu bizarre
c'est un canapé ouais mais il y a un
fauteuil non sur son canapé
un dossier de fauteuil pas à monter
ouais
c'est le bordel
donc demain le dernier quart apparemment
on nous disait tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait encore un changement de programme
et donc peut-être
qu'il va y avoir du speech jeudi
vendredi et mardi
terrible
est encore en lit soit il joue demain
elle a programmation est vraiment kata
en fait ils ont ils ont tous sur le foot
quoi
beaucoup de matchs sur le foot
pendant la demi-heure ouais c'est un peu
ils ont pas vraiment pensé à
ils avaient plus de possibilités de
faire quelque chose que nous
c'est sûr que
nous on n'a pas eu de chance ça va être
de tomber sur sur le match de la France
on pouvait pas vraiment faire autrement
qui me contactent pour en organiser une
deuxième pour vous dire après je sais
pas c'est vraiment une question d'argent
c'était vraiment une dinguerie un
tournoi
donc évidemment et déjà
des intérêts pour en faire une deuxième
ah ça va être le tournoi d'échec le plus
attendu en France maintenant de l'année
mais peut-être sera pas à Paris la
prochaine
pour vous dire la vérité là c'est
plusieurs c'est même pas une et
plusieurs agglomérations qui m'ont
contacté pour essayer de faire ça autre
part qu'à Paris important quand même
bien sûr
le vrai sud ou le faux Sud non vrai Sud
vrai Sud
peut-être Paris toi non pas du tout pas
du tout aucun rapport
mais après
on verra après moi c'est pas sûr que
j'habite encore je sais pas ce que je
vais faire
c'est pas sûr que je suis encore ici
l'an prochain alors je sais pas en vrai
on va mettre le
compteur
toujours être au sud de toute façon
plus côté bike u puisque tu es Mazet moi
je sais pas encore mais ici c'est
vraiment trop cher
c'est problématique avec la petite qui
arrive là c'est problématique
ma femme peut plus travailler en tout
cas pendant un moment on aimerait bien
qu'elle travaille pas si on peut le
faire tout ce que je travaille moi ce
serait
c'est cool si ma femme
peut ne pas bosser et du coup
on n'a pas forcément assez de assez de
moyens du coup
allez ça va partir
hop
on doit à peu près avoir les bons
chronomètre
donc
à faire pousser 5
tu comptes que sur les ventes de place
pour te rembourser tu veux pas faire une
formation participatif si mais tu vois
récolter 450000 euros pour un temps
comme ça c'est dur un midnight
je préfère essayer de trouver des
sponsors ou de l'argent public on leur
en donne tellement
mais après c'est pas
[Musique]
pas vraiment
mais après moi je suis pas dans le bon
je suis pas trop dans la bonne case pour
venir gagner ma vie ici
je suis sur le pire statut possible mais
peu importe ça se calme il donne rien
ben non mais c'est des gros budgets
c'est des gros budgets faut pas croire
tournoi comme ça c'est difficile et puis
contrairement au club au fédérations et
tout tu vois des trucs comme la bécamp
l'état quand il faut nous prendre du
fric il est il est plus que là mais on
n'a pas vraiment accès au subventions
donc on est doublement pénalisé tu vois
donc c'est pas
c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile c'est non seulement
nous en donne pas en plus on nous en
prend tu vois c'est un peu Robin des
Bois à l'envers
donc ouais c'est pas
c'est pas facile on est du côté des gens
de faire beaucoup mais
on se fait surtout prendre beaucoup
après
et après on suit donc du coup c'est
difficile d'organiser genre d'événements
pas que à cause de ça mais notamment
donc on verra je sais pas je verrai
comment je verrai comment je m'organise
pour la prochaine mais c'est pas c'est
pas facile
donc je m'organiserai peut-être
différemment j'aime pas trop le système
non plus avec les subventions et tout
faut peut-être juste payer moins
d'impôts et
avoir plus d'argent pour faire pour
faire des events on verra
on verra comment je me débrouille et
puis et puis sinon enfin peu importe
mais c'est pas évident de faire une
deuxième
une deuxième édition comme ça donc
demander des dons aux gens c'est c'est
un peu bête quoi
donc
cavalier j'ai 5 ouais donc il attaque
simplement le cavalier H5
c'est ok pour un mais pas à long terme
ouais c'est ça c'est moi ça va que ça me
coûte de l'argent de ma poche ça me
coûte du temps ça me coûte de la santé
tu vois et je vais évidemment faire une
deuxième une deuxième édition parce que
c'était trop un gros succès c'est une
première mondiale et c'est un succès de
ouf donc forcément je vais en faire une
deuxième mais faut que je fasse un tout
petit peu attention à moi maintenant que
j'ai ma fille qui arrive et je peux pas
juste [ __ ] ma santé puis avoir de
santé à 40 ans et plus pouvoir
travailler parce que
c'est parce que je suis malade et pas
avoir d'argent parce que j'ai je me suis
tout fait prendre en fait
c'est un truc c'est un truc qui est plus
possible maintenant que je vais avoir
une fille donc ouais c'est joli là ce
qui est en train de faire
après une quête à santé stress bah ouais
tu sais faire 50-70 heures de boulot
tous les ans tous les
toutes les semaines depuis l'âge de
25 ans puis j'ai commencé à bosser à 18
à un moment donné je sais pas si je
pourrais bosser jusqu'à jusqu'à 60 ans
tu vois
donc je peux pas me faire Ken tout le
temps en fait
je veux dire financièrement sur sur un
tas de trucs
donc là c'est un truc j'avais vraiment
envie de faire ce que c'est c'était un
de mes rêves tu vois
d'organiser un événement comme ça mais
je peux pas tout le temps tout faire
enfin je vais pas tout à perdre mais je
peux pas faire des trucs comme ça
complètement à pertes en fait c'est pas
possible
donc on verra je réorganiserai une c'est
sûr à 100%
mais les modalités j'ai pas encore
les modalités j'ai pas encore parce que
tant que j'avais pas ma ma petite fille
qui va arriver je pense un peu d'y fin
je pensais différemment mais c'était
différent ça change quelques trucs en
fait
ça change quelques trucs dans
dans l'appréhension de ces choses-là
parce que tu te dis moi bon après moi le
déluge je m'en branle au pire là tu peux
plus trop penser comme ça
je peux plus dire bon après même si j'ai
plus vraiment d'argent et que je m'en
branle tu vois de base mais là c'est un
peu différent maintenant donc
tu peux plus autant faire n'importe quoi
donc je suis obligé de penser à faire
des trucs qui soient qui sont pas que
dans l'intérêt de tous mais aussi dans
mon intérêt personnel
donc donc voilà
bon il va la tenir salam Magnus
comment ça se faire vieux ouais
y'a pas de ton projet 7 je crois qu'ils
ont tous les deux ratés
ça
mais c'est mieux au blanc maintenant
Fabi qui peut qui peut repeindre
mais tu prends un G7 c'était pas trop
dur pour moi avoir tempo parce que
j'étais en train de penser à ça
ça va être nul
pas mal joué et tout F4 sur les pieds
jaunes
ce qui va faire un tour des quatre pour
se faire qui fait non
il va quand même tenter de la gagner
j'imagine
ce qui a que les Blancs qui peuvent
sur tout il peut jouer plus facilement
plus vite que toutes ces pièces sont
défendues
j'ai envie d'y arriver encore plus suer
le match même si le match est déjà
complètement terminé
ça peut encore plus
quelques coups vite
terrible fil le Punto en un
c'est terrible oh il a pas pris la dame
en un
c'est pas tombé pour un dixième de
seconde côté Fabi
ouais sa chatte complètement en fait ça
voit rien côté Fabi
encore à une seconde
pas une seconde pardon en dixième de
seconde
c'est trop mais ça va pas suffire
et allez ça fait plus simple
ça fait marrer Magnus et oui pourquoi tu
joues Fabiano ouais ils savent même pas
pourquoi ils jouent là il faut pas se
faire d'illusion
là ils savent pas pourquoi ils jouent
c'est terrible
t'en prends juste c'était pour un
cavalier F5 échec
je vous avais dit que c'était très bien
bon allez 5 points d'écart
le match est déjà est déjà pliant
encore une heure 45
1h45 deux heures de jeu pour être bien
sûr
sympa les matchs depuis hier
très à sens unique
allez il faudra encore une petite
victoire de Magnus c'est plus six
histoire d'être encore plus sûr ils ont
le droit d'abandonner non non on est
obligé d'aller jusqu'au bout au moins on
est vraiment bien sûr
bah ça fait marrer oui oui mais il y a
plus de match en fait c'est ouais c'est
ouais c'est le système de comptage n'a
absolument aucun intérêt mais ça on le
sait
c'est comme ça et c'est toujours été
comme ça et ce sera comme ça l'an
prochain et vous revenez dans 10 ans ça
aura toujours pas changé mais oui dans
les matchs comme ça
qui sont la majorité des matchs c'est
ouais c'est bon ça a pas d'intérêt quoi
et là on va rentrer dans la phase où les
deux joueurs vont un peu troll
et jouer plus tranquille
du moment du moment que les que les
affiches sont pas serrées les matchs
prennent les scores prennent trop
d'ampleur
absolument rien à Magnus il est
nettement trop fort mais c'est juste que
faire un format de 16 Blitz contender
c'est 3 1 3 1 et tu fais en 3,7 gagnant
il va gagner à 3 1 3 2 mais
bon voilà enfin merci au revoir en fait
là il y aurait deux sept 0 on
commencerait le troisième est-ce que
Carole peut faire un retour on pense pas
on sait jamais s'il gagne un set il perd
le troisième merci au revoir mais tu
gardes de l'enjeu tout le long du truc
là oui bon ça juste aucun intérêt mais
tu veux y faire quoi en fait
c'est comme ça là les joueurs les
joueurs n'y sont pour rien le format
fait que
là maintenant depuis allez on va dire
depuis 19h45 19h50 il y a déjà quasi
plus de suspense bon là maintenant c'est
vraiment
voilà c'est fini quoi
trop d'écart de niveau entre les deux et
Magnus bah qui a prouvé qu'il était plus
fort et juste là en plus les belettes à
la fin ça va être encore pire pour
Fabiano
mais là mise à part attendre la fin du
match mesdames et messieurs
plus grand chose à faire surtout que
l'intensité baisse en fait quand c'est
clair
donc c'est comme ça
ça part encore à trois ça perd tout
ouais
donc de truc c'est que ça devrait aller
vite quand même
elle formate 7 est tellement meilleur
mais c'est moins bien pour les
annonceurs
presser un calcul je trouve un peu à
court terme mais
ça c'est quelque chose qui existe dans
tous les sports et c'est pour ça que le
tennis a essayé de ce jour en terme en
terme de temps aussi à pas si longtemps
je sais pas si j'ai vu pendant la
période covid il y avait des exhibitions
tennis où les matchs se jouaient pas
avec un comptage de points ordinaire
comme les 7 mais ce jouet avec un en
terme de temps
et en fait c'est parce que les
annonceurs payent plus cher parce que
c'est plus facile de savoir combien il
va y avoir de pub et combien il va avoir
de temps d'antenne
et donc le tennis a essayé de se mettre
au format speechers en tout cas pour les
exhibitions pour faire le test et
évidemment ça fait un flop parce que ça
correspond pas du tout au jeu comme les
échecs ou le tennis qui sont des jeux de
duel et qui vont pas du tout avec ce
système de comptage mais ça a quand même
été tenté pour cette raison et là c'est
un peu la même chose donc à court terme
c'est un très bon calcul sur une saison
de speechers c'est sûr que ça rapporte
plus de le faire avec ce format là
financièrement c'est plus intéressant
par contre moi je suis convaincu que sur
le long terme bah c'est pour ça que
personne regarde des échecs parce que
comme tous les tournois en que des
formats claqués bah les gens
s'intéressent pas sur le long terme au
jeu et donc finalement ça fait perdre de
l'argent évidemment et c'est pour ça que
c'est pas rester au tennis mais
c'est un calcul court thermiste en fait
à court terme ce format est plus
intéressant
donc si on regarde un speech sur une
saison c'est sûr que ce format est
meilleur je parle financièrement parlant
après si tu regardes sur 5 saisons juste
tu ton jeu et tu tues ton ta compétition
mais
c'est comme ça
il va encore la gagner je pense Magnus
et une qualité de moins mais il est
mieux
il peut faire plus 6
après l'avantage des échecs c'est comme
tout est déjà tellement inintéressant et
mal fait
tu pas vraiment parce que
enfin c'était c'était déjà mort avant
quoi donc tu fais pas vraiment beaucoup
de mal
puis bon le speech c'est pas non plus la
compétition qu'on attend
dans l'année on aimerait bien déjà que
les matchs championnats du monde et
genre de choses soient bien organisés
j'aime bien me faire l'avocat du diable
mais en l'occurrence je ne trouve pas
d'arguments à poser ce que vient de dire
Kevin ouais malheureusement
même ceux qui veulent me contredire
juste par plaisir
d'argumentation là c'est dur de ouais
malheureusement il y a rien à dire même
quand tu veux aller à l'encontre de ce
que je viens de dire c'est la
triste vérité et la Carlson je crois
qu'il a troll mais bon et là le problème
c'est que ça joue plus à fond maintenant
ça troll
là tu as tout le monde qui troll le
commentateur les joueurs
regarde quand même l'avantage ça ça
s'appelle un punto ça a été raté en un
par Faby
c'est pas de bol
Fabi ah ouais qui se fait enfermer la
tourrelle
allez là maintenant il y a d'autres ah
c'est pas vu par Magnus G2 échec c'était
quand même une fourchette en un là c'est
du turbo troll là
là c'est du turbo troll
là ils ont tout raté les deux
exceptionnel
j'ai deux faciles ouais mais bon enfin
voilà c'est ouais
enfin pas plus rien à [ __ ] mais genre
c'est
c'est dur de rester concentré quand il y
a plus de tension
ça se comprend
là c'était facile quand même
magnifique qui se marre ouais parce
qu'il a raté un truc trop facile mais
bon dur de maintenir la concentration à
100%
26 à 1 une fois ou un truc comme ça
enfin quelque chose à un ouais
je crois que c'était Hikaru contre
Maxime demain pendant le match du Maroc
comment c'est facile pendant le France
Maroc
aussi ou quelque chose comme ça
du coup parler un peu de choses des
autres pour la partie
ça joue sur la colonne des
ça déjà 8 carreaux contre parano
peut-être ouais on avait eu par exemple
contre quelqu'un de fort il était pas
bien par âme
on avait eu un parram qui s'était fait
défoncer mais je sais plus par qui
mais je rappelle qu'il était pas bien
ouais
donc demain ça commence à essayer de
19h23 heures le match le Maxime
donc le plus important ton bras en plein
pendant le match
bon là il domine complètement la partie
encore une fois avec les Blancs
t'as même pas avoir l'impression que ce
soit cher payé pour car wanna
première meilleur joueur d'échec au
monde
Carlsen n'est pas Dingler
niveau de 40
non la plupart des joueurs se font
défoncer par Carlsen
il a moins d'élo je vois pas pourquoi il
serait de quoi
si tu devais en mettre un si on a un qui
pouvait avoir sa place entre ces
trois-là ce serait fille ou déjà parce
qu'on sait pas exactement comment il
joue maintenant vu qu'il peut progresser
très vite mais n'a qu'à bien sûr que non
tu rigoles
c'est une caméra cachée il calcule G5 là
calcule G5 FG vous prend puis on prend
F6 puis on prend H6
et ça marche
ah c'est terrible pour Fabien
alors après peut-être qu'il peut encore
défendre via fouder 8
non mais c'est beau quoi Joe Bava qui
aurait plus de chance complètement au
hasard en fait
un jobava complètement au hasard
Sébastien Mazet ouais complètement au
hasard aussi
ça gagne peut-être pas pour pour
magnouche
7 il va faire 3 ici
15 et ça doit être nul parce que le fou
va rester sur la bonne case attention
quand même maintenant le roi va revenir
terrible il a pas fou et 5 il faut
penser 5 et alors rêve 43 prend il va
repartir peut-être je sais pas c'est
peut-être nul mais ça va être chiant
qui perd le Punto quand même
ça du coup c'est
j'ai pas l'évaluation mais ça me semble
gagnant pour les blancs en fait
il va faire ses 5 C6
allez faut cliquer
si c'est réussi
et ça fait plus 6 bon bah je vous avais
pas menti quand je vous ai dit que le
match avait aucun suspense
il y a vraiment pas de suspense c'est
waouh extraordinaire
le top 3 monde change pour toi alors
l'ordre c'est sûr parce que Hikaru
il sort évidemment de top 1 voir même de
top 2
mais à Paris car où ça doit être assez
assez semblable
à la fin
dans la cam oui
ça va être tellement chiant à jouer pour
caroanna
en fait tu sais que c'est d'aide tu sais
que ça joue plus pour rien
tu sais que c'est long quoi
mais demain le début de match a été
vraiment dur Cyril parce que non
seulement il a perdu les deux premières
mais en plus après il a eu deux trois
bonnes positions qu'il a pas réussi à
gagner
il a pas le droit d'abandonner le match
non qu'est-ce que ça doit être chiant
qu'est-ce que ça doit être relou
depuis son lieu de vacances depuis son
hôtel en vacances
il avait vraiment pris le truc à la
légère et il était devenu champion du
monde de Blitz
trois semaines après
l'an dernier Maxime il avait joué
totalement à l'arrache le
il sortait d'une grosse saison machin il
y avait eu les le grand Suisse enfin il
avait besoin d'une pause il est sorti
d'un truc de fou
il était sur les lieux du Championnat du
Monde Carl Seine n'est pas
à Dubaï c'est ça
qui est déjà des remontes 6 points déjà
je crois pas mais en plus là c'est pas
un truc contre le cours du match ou quoi
la différence de niveau elle est
monstrueuse il peut pas y avoir il peut
pas y avoir de remonter c'est terminé là
il va y avoir une pause quand même une
petite pause de 5 minutes elle va faire
mal celle-là pour Fabio aussi de pause
vous allez voir que le Bullet ça va pas
être mieux
c'est quoi son secret à Magnus by
calcule bien calcul vite et il a un
placement de pièce naturelle magnifique
calcul son point faible ouais c'est son
point le moins fort le calcul à Magnus
mais en fait son placement de pièces est
tellement fort
par rapport à la force de son placement
de pièces sont calculées suffisamment
bon
terrible ça c'est nul
allez cacher le roi là-bas
on peut pas progresser avec les Blancs
je crois que c'est la pause
important la petite pause là
ça aurait été complexe
sans ou c'est tout travailler
ah bah c'est il a enfin forcément du
travail mais il faut réussir à le mettre
en place
donc ça fait 9 3 Magnus
très très facile à Magnus
très très facile
a joué c'était sûrement un grand Chaft
tour non cet été
je pense
j'imagine
on attend la fin de la pause je crois
que c'est 5 ou 6 minutes
il est vraiment trop fort
on va avoir une façon on attend un petit
à petit la fin du match on va pas se
mentir on attend que ça se termine
[Musique]
après il y a encore une demi-heure
on en a ça termine dans une heure 20 en
gros
après ça repart demain
pour l'ultime
ultime partie
pour le team partie du tournoi
parce que quand on a le droit de Rachid
non non il a pas le droit de rage quitte
ça ira jusqu'au bout il faut attendre on
faut attendre jusqu'au bout pour que le
match soit terminé il y a pas le choix
c'est un système de temps c'est pas un
système de donc les parties s'enchaînent
jusqu'au bout ça s’enchaîne jusqu'à ce
qu'on a
pas de choix
non mais bon c'est juste que ça fait 6
ans que c'est comme ça enfin ça n'a
aucun intérêt mais c'est comme ça c'est
jusqu'au bout quoi
après revenez demain pour le match de
Maxime mais sinon là le match est
terminé à moins que vous vouliez voir
des parties pour voir des parties mais
là il y a plus d'intérêt sportifs
ça a rien d'inventer un suspense ou quoi
que ce soit demain le match de Maxime il
recommence et puis on verra s'il est
serré ou pas serré mais celui-là il est
il est plié vendu terminé
j'attends je garde mon téléphone et je
regarde pas le foot
après tu sais je regarde pas le foot si
j'avais pas le speechage je regarderai
pas le foot non plus je te rassure
tout le temps en pause ouais il y a pas
mal de pause ouais
demain
les algorithmes
on va voir est-ce que Magnus peut encore
faire enfler le score
70-30 ouais l'algorithme
donc
là
dur à dire mais peut-être je sais pas
j'en sais rien j'ai pas pensé mais
peut-être pas il y en ait pas loin en
tout cas
merci olé you elle est vanne c'était
cool
en fait
tout type de format un petit peu comme
ça maxime a juste jamais gagné contre
Naka juste toujours perdu
ok ça va prendre le Punto
max
donc quand tu es aussi nettement plus
fort en longue généralement
tu es aussi nettement plus fort en blitz
on sait que Maxime arrive à gagner
Magnus c'est pas un alors d'ailleurs
déjà Magnus a pas maxime a pas un bon
score contre Magnus
premièrement et deuxièmement
juste le duel direct
et très mauvais pour Maxime entre contre
Naka c'est une question de style
évidemment Magnus est plus fort que tout
le monde dans toutes les catégories et
dans toutes les cadences en fait
tour 1
que les parties longues et rapides et
demandent complètement séparées c'est ce
que les gens qui aiment les parties
longues essayent de faire croire en fait
ils essayent de faire croire que si on
jouait en rapide ce serait plus les
mêmes joueurs
qui gagneraient
ce qui n'est absolument pas le cas mais
comme ils veulent surtout pas qui est de
changement ils font croire ça
sera considéré ma guise sur une
vingtaine d'années une légende de juste
un champion du monde une légende
il a trop de minet
il a été trop trop fort
ça va faire encore Punto pour Magnus on
discute un peu d'échec à côté parce que
voilà mais ça va encore faire un point
[Musique]
ça va encore faire un punto
difficile à dire quand il laissera la
place de numéro 1 d'ailleurs bah il est
en quelque sorte laissé en défendant pas
son titre
mais évidemment il reste le meilleur
joueur du monde
ça va être long pour Fabiano ouais ça
doit être relou là pour Fabian
ça va être relou pour Carlson aussi
moi
honnêtement
car Wana ouais il y a un peu plus de
gaffe dans son jeu
c'est pas mal joué ça il va réussir à
faire à 6 puis à 7 s'il avait échangé
pris H5 la dalle en B7 couvrait et
couvrez le Punto
et ça fait plus 7
ça enchaîne
ce leçon ouais c'est trop en fait
ça suffit quoi
c'est un genre de film tu regardes 5 10
minutes quoi tu regardes pas pendant 4
heures normalement
il a pas le droit d'abandonner le match
alors d'abandonner des parties
mais il est obligé de jouer jusqu'au
bout
c'est terrible
notamment se faire chier ouais il doit
se faire chier ouais
franchement c'est une torture ce truc
en fait c'est match c'est une torture
physique et mentale
ça s'apparente d'abandonner en fait on
est enfermé dans une boucle en fait on
est dans une boucle ou on doit suivre ce
match quoi
c'est un genre de premier niveau des
enfers en fait c'est match
en fait Dantès quand
il a décrit les enfers il a oublié le
speedchasse
quand au fait qu'il y a 6 ans c'était la
cruelle à bagnard pour voir le champion
du monde à l'écran c'est absolument faux
et
j'avais été la croix et la bannière de
voir Magnus Carlsen
[ __ ] c'est phrase à la con quoi c'est
ça
ouais non
ouais c'est sûr
faut faire parler les prisonniers ouais
avec nous pendant trois heures on lui
tape la discute ouais non j'ai pas
compris ouais ouais
il a une bonne position je pense
là ça se peut qu'il remette deux trois
points Fabi tout d'un coup
et Manu ce qui va appuyer sur
l'accélérateur en belette
il s'en fiche que tu critiques la
revente sur le stream FR a complètement
que c'est justifié
là on peut pas me dire l'inverse que le
match il est pas terminé et que les
joueurs ça les fait chier de jouer le
match en fait c'est juste le cas
ouais
du moment que c'est vrai il y a pas de
souci
c'est l'avantage
c'est l'avantage des choses vraies
mais là on va pas me dire que carvana il
est heureux de
devoir encore subir
les assauts de Carlson
c'est le seul à dire
ouais mais c'est possible parce que je
suis plus connu que les autres la
plupart
en fait tu as faut dire que
ouais moi je dis un peu ce que enfin je
sais pas comment dire mais j'ai pas de
tu as fait le même statut non plus tu
vois
je fais plus que j'ai envie quoi
enfin moi personne va
force à dire quoi que ce soit ou quoi
et oui les Américains après ils sont
toujours en train de pépon tout ce qui
est possible de pépon c'est aussi
tu as l'impression que tout est
historique avec un
dans quoi il y a ça aussi
les chevilles vont bien le problème
c'est que c'est vrai en fait enfin
tu préfères la fausse modestie parce que
tu aimes bien les gens qui te font pas
qui qui prennent les autres pour des
nier ou des Auris
je déteste prendre les gens pour des
débiles
dire que je suis un streamer d'échec
lambda c'est de prendre pour un con en
fait mais si tu as mis un compte prenne
pour un con ça c'est tu as d'autres
stream
à peine ouais là il est passé de
complètement gagnant à foutu encore une
fois il arrive plus à jouer en fait les
parties en plus d'intérêt en soi
les gens des fois j'ai l'impression que
c'est un truc que vous avez du mal à
maîtriser aussi c'est la fausse modestie
c'est les gens qui font des phases
modestes mais tu vois qu'en fait ils
sont pas vraiment modestes c'est un truc
que j'ai remarqué que ça paye tellement
souvent les gens
il y a peut-être si on prend des deux
pour du Tour à un mat
qui peut passer
mais la fausse modestie j'ai
l'impression que les gens il a il a
ils sont complètement bête par ce truc
là
et ça arrive tellement souvent
plus souvent qu'on ne le pense
je vais pas me
mettre à faire de la fausse modestie
pour rien ouais c'est Magnus ouais qui
est même écurie de la victoire parce que
c'est trop
ça quand je vous dis ouais même Fabiano
lui-même il en a marre de jouer ça enfin
quand tu joues comme ça que tu perds
tout que ça te fait chier comme ça c'est
horrible
il y a trop d'écart dans le match
donc tu vas plus jouer aucune ouverture
intéressante déjà que de base tu allais
pas en jouer parce qu'il y avait trop
d'écart mais là même si tu
semblais pouvoir avoir un onze d'envie
de jouer un truc intéressant tu vas pas
le faire tu vas le garder pour un truc
où tu as une chance
on sait qu'il y a que 8 passes entre 7
et 9 parties en belette généralement
c'est quasiment même mathématiquement
terminé déjà alors que tout est fait
pour qu'il y ait plus de parties à la
fin même si on peut pas faire de gros
écarts
c'est kata pour Fabi elle a encore un
les ouvertures c'est pas Magnus là qui
est un peu en troll
moi la corde voilà ça change plus grand
chose
bon je sais pas il a l'air quand même
d'être détente en famille c'est que il
sait qu'il en a encore plus que pour une
heure
ce qui est beau après c'est les pubs
quand même au milieu les pauses
ah je pense qu'il va la gagner quand
même Fabien à force la Magnus j'ai
l'impression qu'il
il va quand même pour des trucs un peu
un peu tout match
on va voir il va essayer de faire [ __ ]
ça marchait pas
il reste encore 8 minutes il reste
encore deux gammes dans cette cadence
qui a l'enfer
ce qu'il fallait faire c'est Magnus
là j'en ai marre que tu poses 10 mille
fois la question tu me saoules
c'est pas possible de ces cent mille
fois la question
c'est bon je suis pas votre daron
non non il joue pas trop et toi sur
Internet comme ça ils sont fous
complètement à lire et ça
il a pas tort
il est sur ses objectifs sur ces trucs
pourquoi pas
il va se retrouver mal en plus erwana
mais il arrive plus à jouer là en
famille il a plus aucun coup bon c'est
je sais pas comment s'est passé j'ai pas
regardé en détail mais je tends les yeux
je balade un gars et tout et il passe de
mieux à moins bien quoi
c'est un peu comment
tu en parleras j'en sais rien moi il
fait ce qu'il veut pas parler de joint à
title que que un truc comme ça tu as
bien la différence et là tu cliques
c'était pas là tu cliques pas quoi
il est déjà rediff sur la chaîne rediff
de jeu
proche de quatre joueurs pro Maxime
non mais les titles
mais tout le monde comprend pas ces
trucs là je sais pas des fois c'est
bizarre non ça me paraît évident mais
après je me dis c'est vrai que quand tu
joues pas trop échecs c'est pas évident
d'un autre côté vous regardez quand même
les stream
vous voyez bien que les title tout le
monde s'en fout
que tout le monde joue tranquille
c'est pas du tout la même intensité que
ça si ça clique bien ça clique ça clique
pas du coup il
tu as pas une obligation de performer
il va encore la perdre Fabi ouais mais
c'est il se fait retourner chaque game
mais bon et juste il est il est plus
capable de jouer
ça le fait marrer
c'est quasiment trop mais ouais
il a plus la concentration
a passé tout l'intérieur en fin de match
hier défoncer le format c'est bien qu'il
y a un problème
à base de c'est une perte de temps pour
tout le monde ouais mais c'est en fait
tout le monde le dit
elle aussi en c'était l'an dernier je
crois qu'il l'avait dit il y a 2 ans
après un match il avait dit je crois que
tout le monde le dit en fait
tout le monde le dit depuis plusieurs
années mais oui évidemment c'est trop
c'est trop long et Hikaru qui est
créateur de contenu en plus maintenant
avec sa chaîne twitch et tout il
comprend bien que ok c'est trop
et là on voit les quarts de finale ça en
fait deux qu'on voit coup sur coup hier
et aujourd'hui et ok on tombe sur deux
matchs catastrophiques
regardez la demi car le Carlson Fabi
normal en fait bah oui
mais oui il a raison
après tu peux être surjoué dire que
c'est extraordinaire mais là Fabiano il
joue plus mais réellement enfin je vous
le dis vraiment là c'est plus
CATIER des cas il se fait défoncer
toutes les parties il est encore
complètement foutu
il peut plus jouer en fait c'est comme
quand vous me voyez turbo God 27 80 à 26
80 et je clique comme ça et je sais même
pas pourquoi en fait
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
faire Kawana
je pense que Magnus met ce temps à 99%
des gemmes mais il y en a 99,9% des
gemmes c'est pas Kawana le problème
c'est juste que là il peut plus jouer ça
sert à rien en fait
c'est comme si au tennis fallait gagner
12 jeux pour gagner un match que tu
mènes 13 jeux à deux et qu'on dit ah ben
tiens on va encore jouer 13 jeux de plus
enfin j'en sais rien enfin le nombre qui
reste les 10 jeux qui restent on va
quand même les jouer
bah ouais ça sert à rien quoi
tu peux plus quoi tu cliques mais enfin
je sais même plus pourquoi tu joues tu
sais plus rien en fait
le score est lourd tu as perdu le match
tu as perdu tu sais pas pourquoi tu
joues en fait
perdre de l'eau gratuitement je te
rassure que les lots de chaise comme il
s'en foutent
de 7 comme au tennis est bien meilleur
c'est pas c'était pas très dur à avancer
brattaque en même temps
donc ouais c'est sûr que
[Musique]
voilà la partie encore d'une seule
mauvaise qualité j'ai l'impression
enfin ça joue pas enfin honnêtement
mieux que moi attention mais
sans qu'il y a pas trop de fil à tiens
il reste plus que c'est terminé pour
cette cadence ça va faire du bien à Fabi
de savoir que ça s'arrête après le
Bullet il va prendre cher mais belette
au moins juste tu cliques je t'emmerde
de moi en belette
va c'est pas la fille d'un
Evan feed
c'est juste dans les échecs les gens
sont bizarres ils ont pas le même
[Musique]
il va pas la même chose que le monde
entier
noir c'est dur
c'est la piquette Jack
en gros il reste entre 8 et 9 parties
après 30 7 et 9 parties après
il en a gagné une au moins non il en a
même pas gagné
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé même j'ai
envie de te dire même côté Carl Seine
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé de le
laisser gagner enfin laisser gagner non
mais je veux dire par là voir jouer un
peu plus tranquille
on va voir s'il a réussi à tenir
on est tranquille et si tu as réussi à
mater ou pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il a fait n'importe
quoi
la Magnus qui a fait de la merde
est-ce que ça va suffire ou pas
peut-être il a raté dame à 8 Fabi
il a il a complètement raté dama 8
il le trouve maintenant mais trop tard
il y a plutôt reprend le 5 à cause de
Tour Eiffel
et là il se prend une fourchette en plus
tu viens le clôturer Magnus dégoûté du
niveau de jeu et ça fait 10 points
d'écart
c'est terminé déjà mathématiquement
même si Fabiano gagnait toutes les
parties dans la demi-heure à venir ce
qui est absolument impossible il
perdrait quand même
c'est magnifique
ça me fait plaisir des matchs comme ça
quand même
l'algorithme avait pas menti quand il a
donné 98%
mais faut continuer ah bah oui la petite
demi-heure de plus c'est crucial mais tu
te faut que tu ailles regarder en
anglais stand
tu vas voir qu'ils sont sur IP par les
bullets
va voir les commentaires en américain
ils vont être sur IP
et je vous ai donné un 100% de chance
pour Magnus je crois que je m'étais pas
trompé
c'était vraiment 100%
c'est Larousse ouais c'est la roustada
pour de vrai
non il a vraiment dit à identing fabia's
given up there is still time forte Games
non vraiment
non mais ok mais c'est enfin c'est pas
possible de dire autant de la merde de
te prendre autant les gens pour des cons
non mais c'est pas possible
garder les bureaux non mais tu respectes
les gens quand même
mais il y a même pas dit partis en
belette
je sais pas c'est
moi je trouve c'est pas
enfin après moi je peux plus faire
confiance aux gens qui me demandent de
manière aussi est montée je peux plus
faire confiance après
je trouve c'est un peu la même logique à
court terme c'est bien parce que tu
gardes un peu des viewers mais je trouve
qu'il y a moyen terme en fait tu te fous
de la gueule des gens en fait qui va te
faire confiance après
mais comment ils peuvent te vendre comme
bac possible en fait
non mais les américains ils sont très
différents de nous
pour enfants
de pièces
place bien ces pièces naturellement
c'était prévu mais entre le match d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui
celui-là est plus exceptionnel en
quelque sorte
sont plus intéressants stand ah bah oui
mais bon spectacle
qui vous a fait mal
tu pourras arrêter Magnus je sais pas
peut-être la 5G
la police
le scénario du match m'étonne pas du
tout
t'imagines sur un des deux qui se masse
les bras pendant le match
ça pourrait être magnifique
c'est trop
ouais c'est trop les Bron James à tout
moment oui non là ce serait trop
mais j'ai peur qu'à tout moment ça parte
j'ai peur qu'à tout moment
ouais c'est ça Magnus il se décapsule le
gland à tout moment
bon allez de belette plus de 30 minutes
de souffrance pour Fabiano
personne comprend
peut-être l'année prochaine ils vont
enfin changer le truc ou peut-être pas
faut vraiment qu'ils prennent mon idée
de 7
ce serait une telle avancée
tu sais plus pourquoi tu joues et tu te
tapes encore le Bullet tu es pas bien
mais en fait j'ai compris c'est pas
Fabiano qui joue c'est call flow
il s'est fait remplacer par cale Flo
je vais chercher un truc à manger je
reviens pour ce match j'ai pas le temps
ouais ne part pas trop longtemps tu
risques de rater quand même
tu risques en rater beaucoup
voilà
je vais prendre un petit coup Mischa
peut-être
je vous montre Micha ce sera meilleur
des meilleurs moments du match
c'est le nouveau micro
voilà et ben voilà madame vous voulez
repartir
je vais voir si elle veut repartir
elle est repartie
ah oui on voyait un petit peu la petite
madame c'était sympa de voir la petite
madame
elle est gentille comme tout la petite
dame
pas fan du micro bon non la renifler ça
l'a pas intéressé je dois pas comprendre
à quoi ça sert
attention il menace maintenant ça peut
être raté peut-être
ma nuit sur un massage
je te rassure pour Hikaru
il va se faire mater en
il va se faire mater Faby
faut juste dame G7
il peut encore gagner on se parti
d'affilée Fabiano
il peut gagner on se parti d'un filet
ça va
voilà c'est c'était déjà
mathématiquement fini normalement il y
avait 9 parties dans le dans le bolet on
imaginant un truc incroyable et on est
10 bon là maintenant il y a 11 points
d'écart merci au revoir
mais c'est peut-être encore faisable
pour Fabiano
ils peuvent emmener quand tu as dit toi
mais il faut qu'il s'en rappelle
faut les gagner vite ouais faut jouer
vite faut jouer vite là maintenant pour
Fabi
faut vite vite mettre des puntos là
faut vraiment qu'il joue tout tempo
qu'il en gagne 6 7 d'affilée pour avoir
une chance
mais là faut vraiment jouer vite
maintenant Fabiano qui est dans
l'urgence pour revenir au score
on se prend des cars ah il abandonne
bien joué de la part de Faby
c'est bien joué il garde du temps pour
avoir le temps de remonter il y a que 12
points d'écart on a déjà vu des gens
remonter un tel écart
c'est pas impossible les amis il suffit
de gagner des parties en 25 secondes que
Magnus RIP sur la souris et qu'il
abandonne et il pourrait alors revenir
il y a le temps encore il y a le temps
c'est vrai on en discutait de cette
allongement des matchs pourquoi pas
jouer en 14 heures d'affilée ça
laisserait plus de temps pour revenir là
les quatre heures ça me paraît quand
même un peu
il faut vraiment vite vite que ça arrive
sur le bouton abandonner pour magnouche
match d'un intérêt colossal ce soir
un des matchs les plus serrés qu'on ait
eu à vivre un suspense à tout épreuve et
la même encore à 24 minutes de la fin du
match on est bien loin de savoir qui va
l'emporter et bien malin celui qui
pourrait deviner l'issue de ce match
qui n'est pas évidente c'est du 55 ans
encore
ça paraît pas fait
Magnus a peut-être pris une très légère
option
mais rien de décisif bien loin de là
certains charlatans vous feront croire
qu'on ne remonte pas un écart de 12
points mais des carrés minimes
puisque je le rappelle dans les 10
dernières minutes du match
la victoire vaudra 50 points et lors de
la dernière partie la super partie la
dernière partie du match donnera 750
points à son vainqueur et permettra
peut-être peut-être de retourner le
match dans un sens ou dans l'autre
de super banco ouais cette partie qu'on
appelle la partie super banco qui offre
750 points
à celui qui la gagne
rien n'est encore fait en fait je pense
c'est ça qui doit faire chest comme sans
rigoler
en fait je vais peut-être les contacter
je vais leur dire vous faites vous
changez la règle et la dernière partie
du match vaut 100 points
partie super banco
la dernière vaut 100 points
donc celui qui gagne la dernière marque
son point et là vous êtes sûr que le
match sera serré intéressant jusqu'à la
fin je suis sur c'est une idée qui peut
qui peut cloche
au bout d'un moment c'est vrai que si la
dernière partie vaut 100 points le match
serait loin d'être terminé là suite à la
dernière
mais là je sais pas si ça se passe dans
la partie mais bon ça clique
complètement en fait tout le monde s'en
fout
de la game
faudrait mettre 99 game avant ouais et
la centième qui vaut 100 points ça ce
serait beau
je sais pas s'il va gagner ou pas ici
pas d'intérêt sur salle d'avant bah non
mais c'est comme les jeux de télé en
fait il y a plein de jeux télé qui ont
été faits sur ce système de points ou tu
augmentes petit à petit l'importance des
jeux ce qui fait que gagner les premiers
jeux ne
fût quasiment rien sur le résultat final
du truc
donc voilà
c'est fini par le prendre le piège
il y a un intérêt sur les sur le sur la
partie à 100 points c'est annulé
exactement
seulement 13 points d'avance maintenant
les cartes qui restent stables dans ce
match
Manu ce qui réussit pas à faire l'écart
Platon un peu à plus 13 là
rugby ça se rebond plus stress
exactement
si tous les ans pareil
tu as deux trois bons matchs et 12 13
purges
on est on est
j'ai pas les mots on est dans le
ridicule quoi
c'était là première année mais c'est la
sixième ou septième année il y a
peut-être eu déjà au moins 80 matchs
comme avec le scénario plus ou moins
ressemblant à celui d'aujourd'hui
je comprends pas en fait
je comprends pas comment
comment je réussis à monter un truc
comme la BIC up sans budget et comment
je comment regarder ça en fait comment
ouais je ouais j'ai pas les j'ai pas les
rêves en fait
en fait
c'est que je vois c'est cosmique
et encore une fois quand les matchs sont
serrés c'est sympa mais comment il y a
pas un mode ou le mec juste on arrête le
match quoi genre de chaos technique
déjà si ça roule dit maintenant tout le
monde le dit en fait
trop d'écart on arrête ouais moi je
voulais faire un chaos technique genre
tu perds 4 5 parties d'affilée il y a KO
mais tu peux même être ko si tu mets au
score en fait
il s'est refaire arnaquer non mais je ne
peux plus physiquement plus jouer à la
Fabiano ça ça nous arrive à tout ça
arriver Baba qui c'était pareil
aujourd'hui ça arrive mais là il peut
plus en fait
ça fait 17 à 3
ouais
non il a pas le droit d'abandonner
mais ouais ouais
il peut plus jouer il y a plus d'intérêt
il a plus envie de jouer ses terres il
me fait longtemps que je vous dis que ça
le fait chier mais
mais bon quand je le dis personne ne me
croit on dit ouais bah hier j'en parlais
tout on y est machin tu es négatif tu es
machin en fait juste je dis les termes
en fait
le format il est 4 à
enfin pas le format exactement mais le
fait que ça continue c'est cataclysmique
et combien mais je crois qu'il a gagné
plus de 3000 au premier tour donc
peut-être qu'en tout il va toucher 5000
dollars pour ces deux matchs
car ouais
c'est la sixième année on le sait c'est
tous les ans comme ça
si tu m'invente
ça fait au moins quatre ans qu'on le
sait
même le match mvl Naka la finale c'était
pas un plaisir
il y avait peut-être 6 ou 7 points
d'écart avant le début des belettes
c'était déjà terminé aussi
et pourtant c'est vraiment les meilleurs
contre les meilleurs le truc c'est que
le format dans ce format là quand on a
un qui prend le dessus de toute façon ça
va toujours être terminé après
c'est un jeu comme ça c'est une fois que
tu as pris le dessus tu as pris le
dessus mais c'est pas Rio pété mais
c'est pareil dans tout en fait
juste quand tu mets une limite de temps
bah voilà ça c'est
trop là
juste il peut plus jouer il peut plus
jouer ça arrive
tu imagines
numéro 8 mondial tes rude tu viens de
prendre 6 2 6 1 et on dit bah va falloir
que tu joues encore 25 jeux contre
tu as perdu le match bon bah ça va être
compliqué hein
[Musique]
évidemment tu peux plus jouer en fait
mais ce serait pareil dans tous les
sports
Manu c'est même pas lui-même pour qu'il
a donné un pion
mais la cabine bonne position
il n'y a peut-être prises et foussée 5
qui est hyper fort l'ordi donne juste
complètement gagnant parce que on peut
pas éviter mat
[Musique]
des larmes Carana ah ouais mais c'est
triste
c'est pas fait pourra faire ça le sport
c'est terrible c'est matinarable
là on garde une humiliation en fait
voilà
c'est terrible c'est vrai enfin moi je
suis dégoûté en fait de ce que je vois
c'est triste en fait
c'est pas fait pour fin pas fait pour
faire ça en fait
c'est pas fait pour
c'est pas fait pour faire ça
je peux si le problème c'est que je peux
même pas dire le mot de ce que je suis
en train de regarder
un truc hein les gars désolé flemme là
mais je vais je vais même pas je vais
même pas dire le mot
voilà ce qui est en train de se passer
il y a il y a un mot on peut même pas on
peut même pas le dire quoi mais c'est
dur c'est dur
ça commence par V ça commence pas du
tout par V ça commence par eux ça
commence pareil ça dépend votre langage
mais en tout cas ça veut dire la même
chose
ouais une des bacs ouais
il va encore la perdre
enfin il combat pas là en fait il est
chaos debout il est gros il
il est groggy en fait la famille
mais vous vous le voyez qu'il est gros
you il y a que moi qui le voit
c'est l'équivalent d'un chaos là ce qui
se prend il peut plus jouer en fait
ça rien de beau en fait c'est juste en
train de se faire humilier publiquement
là il joue comme comme un joueur
compulsif en fait qui relancé parti
comme un joueur compulsif il se fait
estropier quoi
tu veux un truc en 3 à 7 gagnant tu te
prends 3 1 3 1 3 0 c'est pas 6 millions
que ça en fait
franchement si je veux voir ce genre de
spectacle je vais sur je vais sur pH
très franchement
allez on gagne une famille
[ __ ] il va perdre le plan à 7 oh le
con il perd le pion à 7 il a
complètement oublié oh non
non pas comme ça Fabie pas toi pas
maintenant pas après tout ce que tu as
perdu
il va faire tourner
il va sauver la nul
il est mieux quand même
c'est pas une question qu'il est
injouable saumon c'est que la Fabiano il
joue super mal vous vous rendez pas
compte
il fait des gaffes
hallucinantes en fait
nettement plus fort mais là en fait
c'est juste il peut plus jouer et c'est
tout
vieilli c'est comme Baki tout à l'heure
au ta gueule il a la couche de tournoi
après 5 ans il pouvait pas jouer
petite nul
allez après avec la super partie à son
point
il peut encore revenir
ça peut encore chambouler la partie
mystère ouais
qui va arriver qui vaudra son point
premier à combien c'est une question de
temps c'est 4 heures de jeu c'est pas
une question de points
mais en gros
tu vois il y a 25 26 points dans le truc
donc premier à 13 14
on va dire à 15 points c'est ça d'avoir
gagné le match déjà
ça fait 4 heures qu'il joue là ouais ça
va faire 4 heures 3 heures 40
ça va pas être la dernière encore
car ça n'a pas encore par une partie si
tient jusqu'au bout c'est une première
après il y a eu des matchs il y a des
parties qui ont été donnés
à L'Express
de cette statistique
ça va encore gagner là
pour décompresser ouais là c'est pas une
bière qui lui faut pour décompresser
Ludwig
E
encore une enfilade
c'est dur
[ __ ] mais jamais je jouerai un match
dans ce format là le format est pourra
mais quand tu te fais défoncer c'est
triste quoi
ouais c'est
c'est une horreur
je sais pas comment tu peux rester calme
après ça ouais ça me rendrait fou à
place de Caron
je pourrais pas empêcher de laisser une
victoire ou deux à mon adversaire je
vous le dis premier degré je pourrais
pas continuer à gagner là
j'y arriverai plus en fait j'en donnerai
deux ou trois à l'adversaire juste pour
pour sa santé mentale
ce serait je pourrais plus
d'une période
de trois ça rend pas compte
tu lui dis pas quoi
tu joues un peu en dessous machin tu
fais même pas vraiment complètement
exprès mais tu baisse un peu le
c'est un peu le rythme
il va pas s'en rendre compte en fait
de toute façon
ça reste encore perdu
c'est fou d'avoir vendu le Bullet comme
une chance pour Caravana de revenir
après Carlsen il a un peu fait il a
vraiment très mal joué certaines parties
c'est juste que Fabiano était trop
mauvais pour gagner
ça ça va peut-être gagner pour les Noirs
encore
après ils essayent de tout gagner
ils ont pas fait de la même manière que
nous de façon les champions
là c'est nul ça va se terminer là-dessus
allez au moins il termine pas sur une
défaite la partie à 100 points qui se
termine sur une nulle et du coup qui
laisse qui est annulé qui va pas compter
qui laisse le score à 22 à 4
match serré mais qui se sera il a il a
déco
instantana il a déco instante
la déco instante donc match serré qui se
sera joué vraiment à la fin des belettes
qui se sera joué vraiment à la fin des
belettes dans les dernières secondes on
aurait pu croire à un retour de car
wanna mais Magnus qui a bien bien fermé
la porte dans cette dernière partie et
qui réussit à l'emporter sur le fil à
l'arrache
j'espère que vous avez kiffé on se
retrouve demain pour le match de Maxime
qu'on espère quand même un petit peu
moins serré avec une victoire un peu
plus facile de Maxime qui nous fasse pas
retenir notre souffle jusqu'à jusqu'au
dernier instant comme comme on a pu
vivre ce soir je vous remercie et je
vous dis à demain tout le monde passez
une bonne